what's up with humans hello I'm Ian I'm
Michael and stick around because we're
gonna talk about some cool stuff at the
end of episode in the meanwhile enjoy I
remember on my third day in my first
school here in the US this kid in the
locker room was like so we're part of
Mexico's Columbia I used to work at bars
and I would see like people who are not
Mexican completely disrespecting such an
important part of the history that I've
just like I stay away from it part of
why I'm so turned off by like the whole
concept of how we celebrated in the US
is that you know it was like an excuse
for people to act really out of pocket
and disrespectful and kind of make us
feel like they were doing something
special for us at the same time and I
was like you know I'm not even like
Mexican and this is not what the
struggle is about I like what you said
about you know it's kind of
disrespectful and I agree and that's one
of the big problems that I have with
like other people who are who are
Mexican Americans saying like well I
don't have a problem with it and it's
like well one you probably don't have
any ownership of it like it doesn't mean
anything to you personally and two they
have this concept that like well if more
people are exposed to it then that means
that they'll accept us and it's like nah
that's not how that works it's a day for
me to kind of think about my own
experiences and how I can teach other
people I think us accepting us it's not
really us
who we are they're all we're somewhere
else and I've handlebar mustaches and
eat tacos every day usually people find
out that I'm Hispanic or Mexican because
of my name but it's never because of my
appearance because I'm paler I have
blonde hair people just assume that all
Mexicans are dark and shorter and like
have dark hair but the reality is like
Mexicans come in all sorts of colors
just like America
I've never gotten like you look Mexican
even though I feel like in every Latino
blog I read it's like people always I
assume I'm Mexican other Latino and I'm
just like well it's not really true to
for me I only get called Mexican because
of what you said oh you're latina so you
must be Mexican you know and then I go
explain like you know there's a whole
continent like many many countries and
you know and a lot of Latinos are from
the US like we're the largest minority
we didn't all just comment you know last
week we've been here so it's just
ignorance I super hear that because like
I remember my third day in my first
school here in the US this kid in the
locker room was like so we're part of
Mexico's Columbia I was like so for my
third world country they teach us the
effing world but out here apparently in
like this Silicon Valley you guys don't
get a map
three two one since I've moved to the
bay I've had Mexican Salvadorian and on
duty and parents and students literally
act as if they don't understand me
because I speak in a black Spanish
vernacular I'm just at the point where
I'm just like I'm tired of like acting
as if our language is an educator or
acting as if our language is like comes
from nothing our language comes from
literally everything even though I'm not
fluent in Spanish I'm conversational I
still speak it at work like and all my
customers there they come to me relieved
like when they find out that I can
communicate to them in Spanish and even
though I'm not fluent I do however see a
little dishonor kind of when I go visit
family well I mean like for me in my
experience I kind of had the same thing
where I grew up speaking Spanish and
then I went to school lost it and then
I've regained it as I've gotten older
but like for me I live in a fairly
conservative area like people have
Confederacy tattoos it can be really
intense you know what I mean and for me
there there is still a little bit of
that ear I love that instant affinity
you have with people especially okay I'm
not sure but like people who have left
everything to come here and they're not
even seen and when I speak to them in
Spanish I feel that they feel seen for
the first time and even though we're not
from the same country we don't have the
same experiences I just feel like I have
to and I I I am so I feel so blessed
that I can speak Spanish I just hope
like we just honor our roots and not
just Spanish but like you said there's a
lot of native languages that we should
honor and we sure
practice I kind of like have a bigger
problem with the word Hispanic well I
I'm not in love with the word lucky
necks like I really do love that it's
inclusive of all genders I'm waiting for
the point where there will be another
term because it just doesn't sit right
so I call myself a Latina I'm proud to
be a Latina now I have very dear friends
who are non-binary and they request that
I call them Latin X of course I'm going
to honor that and I am glad that there
is a term that they embrace but I don't
think I should have to say change mine I
think people are gonna call themselves
what they want and they've been doing
that forever I think it's the fact that
when we say Latino or latina we are
excluding trans people in our language
like our language is powerful and I
think that I know where you're saying
cuz I've had this conversation with like
my parents and my aunts like it's worth
a tiny bit of discomfort to include
trans people I'm a teacher like Latinos
are at least my Latino parents that I
see in my schools are so quick to like
the kid could just say something back
like finish a sentence for the parent
the parent is like blah Dani monopod
asana kata and it's like but why though
because I see this other kid who's a
white and it's out here Wallen I spanked
my kids maybe twice their whole life a
little bit it wasn't even like that much
I remember the one time my mom
spanked me and he stayed with me I don't
recommend it I'm not here like a pro
spanking but I think it should be it's
it's somebody's ride to a certain point
I think that some of you know my family
members who haven't had the privileges
of education and the kind of lifestyle
that I have don't have that space
because I remember when I first got to
the u.s. like in Columbia like one we're
a very violent country and I think a lot
of what we see is does that being
replicated into our families but there
was a certain point where my mom was
gonna smack me like that like I would
like talk back tears she's just and when
I was like 13 I just grabbed her hand
midair one time and I was like you know
we're not doing it like this anymore and
I think a lot of that was coming from my
American side spanking to me is a tool
that is easiest it's like if they're old
enough to have a conversation about what
they did wrong then have the
conversation and if they're not old
enough to understand what they did wrong
then why would you hit them spanking is
the hardest thing to do I agree with you
but spanking is the hardest thing to do
[Music]
you guys remember in in the movie Selena
when they're in the van and Abraham is
talking to Selena twice good for the
Mexicans twice as American for the
Americans you know and it's exhausting
yeah and that's more or less where I am
right now and that's why I moved
completely away from national identities
like that's why I don't identify as
Mexican because two Mexicans who are
from Mexico I'm not Mexican enough
that's another thing that I also have an
issue with is just because I'm paler I'm
Wetty
I get thrown into that white supremacist
kind of category that no one really
likes and not literally it destroys me
mentally like it's just no one has the
right to tell you what you are or assume
what you are and it's really just
frustrating I really like that you bring
up that point because I think as a
community we need to do a lot of work
around that in the sense that I have
noticed in my own experience how me
having light skin has definitely yielded
me different results or I've been able
to push different boundaries of I've had
different access because we do have a
lot of things in common you know as a
people we have I know it's not just
language because if you don't speak
Spanish you're still can be fully
embrace evoke the culture so I just love
finding those commonalities between
different you know nationalities
be happy hey guys my name is Michael I'm
Ian thank you so much for watching this
episode of spectrum it's so amazing to
see where people will stand on the line
Michael's the director of all the
spectrum episodes you've ever seen in
your life you know someone told me today
that I have a really good voice really
that's great in the process of making
spectrum as a series what do you think
is something you've learned or something
that's changed with you oh every time I
do this series I learned something new
but the biggest thing I learned is like
no everyone doesn't think the same thank
you for watching you guys
follow us on instagram at jubilee media
we post a lot of different kind of stuff
for you guys and we also love just
interacting with you and hearing your
opinions and epiphanies and your stories
and all that kind of stuff we have so
much more that we want to give to you
guys so yeah follow us on everywhere
everywhere we'll see you around see ya
[Music]
you